what are some of the most important
questions you're asking yourself when
you're developing a story idea I think
who my audience is you know it's a story
interesting enough usually for my horror
stuff it's like is there enough
is there enough stuff in here to care
about the characters but am I also
coming up enough scare so we haven't
seen before those are the kind of things
I ask myself like it's interesting cuz I
love doing it and I've done it for so
long that it's it's definitely it's not
easy work at all like people because
people don't understand like again they
especially when you're threading a
script together and you know dissecting
and making sure that everything kind of
lines up and pieces together you want to
put your best foot forward but you also
realize that a lot of times that once
you sell the script and it's out of your
hands a lot of that stuff just goes out
the window so that's why I'm not as
harsh when I see a movie I like that I
reserve judgment on the writer until I
see read the actual screenplay because
you just never know what changes from
page to screen but for me it's usually
especially because it's always horror
films it's like you know do I think this
is also do I think this is going to
strike a chord of people like you know
final destination dealt with death which
is kind of a universal fear so I try to
think of concepts that will tap into
something that's will reach a wide
audience you know I'm not gonna lie
about that like I do try it you know you
you want to hit as many people as you
can I think with your concept but that's
what I love about horror the horror
genre I think themes are you know the
fears that we have most people are
universal fears that aren't you know
regulated to like one region or one part
of the world or or any you know I think
we all kind of have the same fears deep
down so that's the thing I think a love
about horror is you can kind of tackle a
whole bunch of different kind of stories
and still have it play well around the
world
I like how you use the analogy if it's
like knitting you know and that if you
you know how let's suppose you're
knitting or crocheting something and
then you just pull one little string
here that it can really affect the whole
like you know yeah sweater or whatever
right now people don't realize that when
they it's just when they give you notes
the like I I know at one time I had a
project where a director came in the
producers were all literally like we
think he's full of but we're gonna
give him a shot directing because he'd
write the
a couple things before but his pitch he
kind of came in and had an opening scene
that was because the movie hope the
whole movie built around this plot twist
about these characters not knowing each
other and his opening scene was
basically it was very clear these
characters knew each other and so you
know my first meeting with him I was
like well you know I was trying to be
very diplomatic well how do you propose
that we how do you propose that we do
that opening scene so that we don't
spoil the fact that they know each other
because that's kind of the whole twist
of the script and it wasn't one that's
well you're the writer you figure it out
and so it's like okay you're that's like
the you know I will spoil the end of
usual suspects if you haven't seen that
but that's like that's like going you
know pretend that's you know Kevin
Spacey didn't make it all up in size or
Kaiser so say he's a real person but you
like but the whole point of the movie is
is in and then they're like go or you
know the end of The Sixth Sense it's
like well pretend Bruce Willis is like a
real person and not a guy you notice so
you know when that when they come to do
something like that it gets it's a
little they obviously don't understand
like you're you're taking the core of
what makes this movie like the core
mystery and you're giving it away at the
beginning so that's going to change the
whole movie and then there's a second
you'll figure it out so it's just shows
a certain level of not understanding
about you know how much thought you do
need to actually put into a good
screenplay
you